[Musik]
ich bin da wochen was da rainer pottel
am 17
zu meiner linken der wachtmeister marks
spencer von mirka 2017 und wird zwar
schon heicks wo schwere das berge
fahrzeug vor
wir haben den circa zwei wochen bei uns
da und wird wahr haben
5 welche ausbildung in zwölfaxing macht
darauf auf den fahrzeug und da mag es
wird jetzt einfach mitnehmen ins
vorderhaus erklären wir schauen uns das
ganze von drinnen an
und übrigens geschützt gehörte die
kabine bis kaliber 12,7 mm und minen
sichern
wir sind jetzt in der kabine eingelangt
zum fahrzeug noch selber es ist eine
produktion von emma und rheinmetall
sie kam mit dem fahrzeug fahrzeuge
abschleppen und bergen jeglicher größe
beim bundesheer das fängt an beim
pinzgauer l200 bis zum hof natur oder
zum sattelzugfahrzeug oder den größten
equis die wie immer finden zum fahrzeug
selber noch wenn man eine eigene masse
von 34 tonnen sind knapp elf meter lang
zwei meter sechzig breit und drei meter
80 hoch zu meiner kabine noch selber es
gibt nicht viel was besonderes oder
verschiedene dinge zu einem lkw was ihr
habt ihr habt meinen bildschirm vor mir
wo ich die vier fahrzeug kameras
überprüfen kann und während der fahrt
mit schauen kann
jetzt nehme ich noch mit auf einen
rundgang ums fahrzeug
wir sind jetzt am schweren berge
fahrzeug und sage ich jetzt aber
ausstattungsvarianten oder ein paar
dinge zu am fahrzeug die anzuschauen
sind oder die interessant wären gleich
vor uns haben wir doch unseren lade kann
fürs vom fahrzeug das ist ja hier könne
mit einer maximalen ausladung von sieben
meter auf diesen sieben metern hebt der
knapp 2,8 tonnen beziehungsweise ganz
ran beim fahrzeug eben nur dann bis zu
6,8 tonnen mit dem ladekran keine ein
bauer weg sprich den motor zum beispiel
von einem mannschaftstransportwagen
sanduhr aus dem fahrzeug heben
beziehungsweise kann ich danach was man
dann hinten nachsehen während eine
anhängerkupplung am fahrzeug montieren
dahinter dann geht's weiter mit dem
lichtmasten das ist ein problematischer
lichtmast sprich mit luft aus zu fahren
ist komplett mit led einfach für eine
berge situation in der nacht keine
eigentlich meine berge stelle mit dem
lichtmasten komplett beleuchten bei fürs
fahrzeug selber habe eine komplette
rundum beleuchtung an den stau kästen
montiert dem man dann im nachhinein dann
auch noch sehen werden fast dahinter
geht es dann weiter mit unserer
hauptziele das ist die berge winde mit
einer zug leistung von bis zu 27 tonnen
sprich kann damit jede band uhr außen
größten rausziehen an dem berge am ist
den zudem kommen wir genauer noch einmal
von unten stehen ist die seilwinde
montiert der berge am selber und hier
drauf habe noch meine anhängerkupplung
drauf mit dem mann gesprochen der hebel
mit dem kran einfach nach hinten
herunter ihre drei seilwinden auf meine
fahrzeug montiert wie angesprochen schon
die behr gewinne mit 27 tonnen zug
leistungsabbau 80 meter seil drauf dann
habe ich einen rahmen winter im fahrzeug
die zeigen euch dann auch reinhardt der
kommandant kaum nach vorne und nach
hinten aus geführt werden ist auch eine
selbst bier gewinn der schwäche kaum ein
fahrzeug selber seiner jährige situation
sichern und als dritte winter haben
keine hilfswillige ist circa unter mir
zwar montiert hat eine zug leistung von
einer tonne und 250 meter länge ist dazu
gedacht dass sie das haupt winter sei es
sollte etwas schwerer ist nach ausziehen
kann passt dann schauen wir das ganze
mal von unten an
erst jetzt haben wir da oben machen
einen rundgang
hier sei aber bei staukosten eins im
stall kosten hand befindet sie alles was
sie an adapter braucht für eine vorzeige
aufnehmen
auch die who brille und die gewissen
verzehr von staukosten zwar ist dann
unser persönliche ausrüstung drin und
zwecks rucksack und essen und
verpflegung einmal länger unterwegs
beim staukosten 5 ist noch die ganze
versorgungsleitung was man abschlepper
den vorzeige bringen muss zwecks elektro
und kamera und luft leitungen da hinten
ist noch unser berg der berge am cover
16 tonnen und zusätzlich ein hamster max
aussprachen hat die wer gewinnt mit
diesen fans tonnen
da kommt noch die hilfs winter aus mit
die 1000 kilo wo das abschleppseil dann
oder das bier gestylt dann aussieht
quasi war meine kraft ist da braucht man
es ja vor und seitlich ist doch noch die
rahmen wendete oder kurz gesprochen da
weder seitlich noch mal vorkommen der s
12 tonnen der mann weiter zum staukosten
sex im stau klasse 6 ist bedienungs
einrichtung für den berge berge und kran
und die note bedienung also durchaus als
elektrisches fahren funk mäßig drinnen
meine zwar funk bedienungen und den für
den usa im schaukasten 4s die berge
ausrüstung drinnen wenn man auf verkehrs
um vor ort oder eingeklemmte person hat
da hat man auch den streit zu trennen
und oman auch den trend jäger und die
persönliche bsa und die anschlags mittel
nach die jecken aus dem stau kosten zwar
befindet sich noch die ganze
umlenkrollen drinnen und die
endlosschleifen wobei die bergung
verwendet doppel findet sich unter
12.000 rahmen weiter und jetzt zwei mal
nach was uns auf 550 ps starker hayek
store
[Musik]